sehen sie ihren namen
ich sehe den namen märz ist natürlich
wieder mit märz ganz in diesem sinne
haben kann sich gar nicht mehr einzelne
schwimmt irgendwann unten am montag
es ist es ist halt die kugel bilder
haben sie selber gesehen bevor das nein
gesagt das ist ja kein wunder das ist ja
dass ich gehen soll und bayern ist
außerhalb der galaxien mit der das ist
meine glaskugel ich schon vielfach
benutzt habe noch mit meiner bewegten
karriere dagegen lässt wissen sie immer
so viel besser gesagt hätte ich hätte
jetzt auch noch kurz ihren kontostand
beziehungsweise der entwicklung zusammen
haben sie hat sie aber in ihrem buch
geschrieben haben dass merkel längst
zurückgetreten ist da war hat die
glaskugel war da ja da war die oder war
den bayern muss ich auch ja hab immer
mal auflegen
also lange rede gar keinen sinn wer wird
cdu-chef denn man wird ja wohl ist
deutschland bereit für einen mann an der
cdu spitze ist deutschland bereit für
einen mann im kanzleramt das wäre die
frage also ich müsste mich immerhin
immerhin immerhin hat es ja weiterhin
genießen und dann kanns la riana seite
so viel nämlich dann doch jetzt mal mit
nach ich glaube ich weiß nicht wie lange
ärgere ich mich jetzt als politischer
höchste sonderlich über angela merkel
seit zehn jahren schreibe ich darüber
also und jetzt hat auch der letzte
begriffen dass die eine belastung ist
für ihre partei sie ist an der belastung
für das kanzleramt ist in wahrheit eine
belastung für die ganze bundesrepublik
weise die ganze politische landschaft
der bundesrepublik komplett vertrag
jetzt muss ich mal ganz gut sagte sie
muss jetzt wird nicht weg das ist im
stürmer serge war es ist aber sie muss
jetzt wirklich das gab es ist immer was
los ist
sie gab es gab auch sagen sich auf
twitter stand welt stand schon
weltfrieden auch schon blumen sind bei
allen neuerdings einer meinung ich finde
auch jetzt und nicht die 15 jahre davor
aber die letzten anderthalb bis zwei
jahre so unglücklich dass angela merkel
inzwischen wirklich erheblichen schaden
anrichtet an ihrer partei sie hat ihre
nachfolgerin im parteiamt eine wie ich
finde auch ein böses wort erstickt das
hätte alles nicht sein müssen in dieser
form programm kam bau könnte noch im amt
sein wenn angela merkel sich anders
verhalten hätte vielleicht sogar platz
gemacht hätte schauen darüber vergessen
kommt dann meine gespräche noch in
diesem jahr da hält
noch hält die kanzlerin durch bisher
habe es 21 oder passiert in diesem jahr
wird die kugel hat ja weil sie gar mehr
als unterlage in wahrheit ist es doch in
wahrheit das ist doch die beiden jens
spahn ok herr söder csu
es muss jetzt die wir können auch nicht
mehr dabei war schon falsch es muss
jetzt herzlich
der polit fuchs cdu in meiner rolle als
polit fuchs solchen jetzt folgendes herr
merz hat ein interesse dass es schnell
geht warum so lange der eindruck der
cdu-niederlage cdu desaster in thüringen
gegen die afd
noch frisch ist ist die wunde auch noch
frisch quasi die soviel schmerzen mache
das man sagt jetzt brauchen wir herrn
merz weil das wichtigste was es jetzt
ist ist der fdp entgegen zu treten als
cdu das macht ihn stark solange diese
erinnerung diese wohnen nur noch frisch
ist hat er chancen darum muss er darauf
achten oder darauf drängen ist schnell
sehr lang den märz ich meine ich weiß
war keine witze mit namen aber der
frühling bringt gemerkt und sie sind
dann das blümchen
herr laschet wiederum der 360° anschluss
fähige mensch aus nrw immerhin 17
millionen euro 66 millionen leute könnte
ich gestehe ich kann das ja noch nicht
machen es ist der erste cdu politiker
die ich wählen könnte und entweder ist
es genau ein grund warum er ist nicht
nur könnte sein könnte aber auch sagen
das ist der grund warum er es wird weil
nämlich inzwischen diese bundesrepublik
so weit ist dass die cdu die letzte
volkspartei ist die spd herzlich im
grunde selber aufgelöst und wer hat wie
so ein halbwegs sozial liberalen
regierung haben will und sagt okay den
neoliberalismus kriegen wir nicht mehr
weg der kapitalismus hat gewonnen und
genug geld ist moment auch da um die
gröbsten zu schließen der muss laschet
wer will kann ich lerne dabei
interessant dass sie sehen sie
unterstellen dass man sie haben sich ja
ich weiß ich weiß sie haben führen lasse
einen wahlaufruf gemacht und würzig also
er wird sich bedanken
mancher hinsicht ist das nämlich war
überhaupt ein politiker sich
papierblätter das ist aber in ramat
damit allerdings haben sich natürlich
mit ich war sie wie vielen jahren ihrer
journalistischen tätigkeit gleich mal
schluss gemacht und zwar nicht wegen des
wahlaufrufs sondern weil sie damit
akzeptieren dass die ard bleibt und auch
so groß bleibt wie sie jetzt ist denn
dass das glaubt ja aber ich glaube dass
ja nicht so sein die frage ist doch was
macht die cdu nach angela merkel nach am
ende der ära angela merkels versucht sie
eine hinterlassenschaft neben vielen
guten ist eine wirklich schlecht
hinterlassenschaft dieser er die afd
denn das hat natürlich was mit angela
merkel zu sehen momentan werden sie erst
einmal den gedanken zu entsagen versucht
die cdu noch einmal das rückgängig zu
machen dann muss sie sich ein stück weit
vom fleisch von erbe angela merkels auch
entfernen oder ist zumindest neu
aufstellen neu sortieren oder sagt sie
heute gibt es da am rand zu nach sollen
sagt wir sind weit draußen
diddy diddy die rechten die sich
abgespalten haben die in ihrer
unzufriedenheit weggegangen sind von der
cdu weil es alfred dregger nicht mehr
gibt bald auch walter wallmann nirgendwo
mehr zu finden ist diese leute haben
obdach gefunden bei in einer in einer in
einer gruppe von das ist wie so eine art
räuber waren dann möchte ich was sagen
die haben sich so entfernt gemeinsam von
der bürgerlichen gesellschaft das daran
zurück manama und gar nicht mehr möglich
ist wenn sie einmal auf dem trichter
sind wenn sie einmal auf dem trip sind
deutschland die umvolkung hat angefangen
die islamisierung des abendlandes
überall ein moslem mit dem messer und so
wenn sie einmal diesen weg gegangen sind
ich habe dann sieht sie nicht
resozialisiert wissen sie wollen wir das
erinnert an sein landkarten aus dem
mittelalter oder noch früher ungefähr wo
die erde keine kugel war so eine rasche
wo die osnabrücker unter dach holen dann
fördern die boote so und vielen hinten
runter wenn sie was falsch erachtet man
ja aber das ist doch das stimmt für
einen teil für den bodensatz terium
bildes wort über menschen aber den bogen
satz dieser ard will hat mag das stimmen
diesen vielleicht nicht mehr rückholbar
war sie sich versponnen haben in diese
in diese verschwörungstheorien
klassische werte union
irgendwann stoffe moment aber es gibt
noch eine ganze reihe anderer leute die
irgendwie bei den letzten landtagswahlen
bei der bundestagswahl zum ersten mal
gewählt haben aber vorher 17-mal
internal cdu gewählt hatten und die
glaube ich kriegen sie noch zurück das
geht theoretisch ist die frage ob man es
will
sie drücken und sie drängen sich gerade
sie ist doch sie drücken sich vor der
frage ob die cdu das wollen soll
ich bin doch glücklicherweise weder cdu
politiker noch cdu nach journalist noch
cdu
politische landschaft kann diese nur
sagen ich kann jedoch nur sagen wo
zwischen die sich entscheiden müssen und
natürlich müssen die sich entscheiden
zwischen leuten die sagen ich lasse mir
meinen nackensteak nicht wegnehmen
ich lasse mir meinen diesel nicht
wegnehmen ich habe keinen bock auf
ausländer
deutschland sollte schön deutsch bleiben
und erfurt schöne fotos oder keine
ahnung und die kriegen sie nie mehr
zusammen gedreht mit den modernen
urbanen leuten die die grünen wählen und
ich meine woher soll dann die mehrheit
für die cdu und für unten tanz hat
schwarz grün geht mit merz nicht wenn
merz den um sich ganz kurz werden merckx
der typ ist der kfd spalten soll und
sozusagen den blinken rubel den guten 3d
marina hat wenn der/die zurückholen soll
kann er trotzdem mit den grünen nicht
mehr landen sie in einem bachelor also
erstens glaube ich oder sie sagen die
grünen sitzen runter gerockt dass ich
scheiße gerade ist die grüne laterne ins
fenster und nehmen jeden teller kommt
das kann man auch sagen wie der herbert
strand sommers hamburg herrscht also
hier die wilhelmstraße wird zur
herbertstraße das könnte auch jemand von
der afg sagen dankeschön lieber auf
stand da sieht man dass das hufeisen die
ganze politik das parlament vorerst sich
dass die wahl soll als grüne laterne und
dann sie nehmen jeden tag ist das nicht
auch das könnte man ja fast aufschreiben
das könnte man nicht besser also ich
glaube nur da irren sie wirklich glauben
natürlich kann herr laschet 360°
anschlussfähig hat er schon mehrfach
bewiesen liberaler man der kann mit den
grünen blendend obwohl er gerade das
ohne große kohlekraftwerke 24 ans netz
nehmen will das hat er allein daran
verhandelt weil sie ja sein stand auch
das gemacht hat was aber noch dreckiger
war das ist irgendwie das ich finde aber
die grünen sind auf der zins ohne
einander zu wissen ihre grünen sind
ohnehin aufsetzte ich glaube herr merz
kann die kann seiner cdu werden der chef
würde und dann auch kanzlerkandidat
vielleicht sogar kanzler hätte er seiner
cdu fiel er kompromisse zumuten mit
einem grünen künftigen koalitionspartner
aus so einer position des so
anführungsstrichen falken als herr
laschet dem man sowieso in der halben
partei unterstellt hatten sie die
unterstellt du bist ja in wahrheit ein
grüner du wirst du weiter zurück hätte
man da gesagt nur nixon konnte nach
china gehen das ist sozusagen aber nur
als nur ein general kann frieden ist
dass es in den meisten
fällen einfach historisch irgendwie
unfug ist weil angela merkel ist eben
auch keine sozialdemokratische kanzlerin
sondern hat zeit ihrer angst zeit immer
klientel politik gemacht für ihre leute
deshalb bis heute sind die steuern
deshalb wir tragen die unteren schichten
den größeren teil der steuerlast
sozusagen werden gibt es die
umverteilung von unten nach oben
dies habe sich als ode an die härten der
einkommensteuer hat die sozial
beschreibt die einkommensteuer hat die
soziale spaltung immer weiter zugenommen
weil natürlich die leute am ende eben
die politik für ihre wählern für ihre
klientel machen und märz ist ein in der
wolle gefärbter neoliberaler und würde
auch solche politik machen und er ist
der typ der gesagt hat am asylrecht
müssen wir schon noch ein bisschen
schrauben das wird dann auch für die
grünen schwierig werden wenn man dafür
sein will das geht jetzt zurück in den
ersten parteilichen wahlkampf der hatte
gesagt wenn wir ein europäisches also
wir recht haben wollen dann müssen wir
auch darüber nachdenken inwieweit man
den deutschen asyl paragrafen also
artikel aus dem gesetz anpassen muss
glaube das war alles was er gesagt hat
war und er wollte dass überhaupt ein
absoluter pro europäer ich jetzt gar
keine werbung für hessen was mache ich
mit ihr steht hier nicht weil es um die
cdu geht aber es geht ja aber wir stehen
müssen um das ganze land das geht ja um
die bundesrepublik deutschland wer
müsste ihn natürlich der schrieb darüber
in meiner kleinen kugel ist ja quasi die
polen nach strauß und stoiber will söder
der dritte denkbare kanzlerkandidat der
ich glaube nicht dass jemand wie söder
das quasi qua alter noch nicht muss
jetzt sucht seine chance wahrzunehmen
weil nämlich gar nicht mehr sicher ist
ob die cdu wenn sie den falschen dann
nicht hinter den grünen abschneidet oder
so schwach abschneidet dass die grünen
sagen moment eine grün rot rote
regierung dafür langt auch und da sind
wir ganz ganz albstadt erzählung
lustiger es könnten bisher waren immer
cdu-kandidaten immer dann dran denn die
cdu keinen richtigen hatte oder dachte
sie hat keine richtige chance dann kam
immer an csu kandidat bekam dann immer
seine chance das kannst du doch hier
auch so sein dass man sagt das ist ja
alles so ära merkel vorbei wir haben uns
noch nicht richtig gesammelt da geht
sozusagen die csu die bild und dann zack
wird der typ gewählt weil die leute
sollen wissen mit bayern haben
inzwischen gar nicht mehr so ein problem
und der typ ist irgendwie ganz nett der
ist ganz klar dass herr söder aus den
erfahrungen seiner vorgänger namens
stoiber und strauß gelernt hat unsere
noch mal lasse ich mich von einer
führungslosen cdu nicht verbrennen da
warten wenn man eine schöne runde
denn dieses mal glaube ich könnte es
eben ja auch für noch einmal rot rot
grün oder grün rot rot reichen
rechnerisch 20 bis 20 wenn man das weiß
nicht was irgendwann links trainer und
erst die dritte partei grüne linkspartei
und wäre noch die spd wer ist dass die
spd ja das sind die die zehn prozent
bringen werden zumindest angesagt ist ja
und das geschafft was macht dann auch 84
irgendwo immerhin am ende stellen wir
wählen außenminister würde ich mal sagen
oder die spd sogar in der region ja aber
den 1
zumindest anfangs muss dann natürlich
ist dann ein linker bodo ramelow als
außenminister
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt wo der
ramelow ramelow ist es hat mich wirklich
wenig so geärgert in der letzten woche
wie dies das bodo ramelow ohne mehrheit
aber mit koalitionsvertrag klar
koalition hat man ja halt aber ohne
mehrheit in den landtag geht und sagt
wählt mich und bin ich nicht wählt ja
sagte der zuletzt hat der beliebteste
politiker dort 70 prozent der deutlichen
billigen ich bin auch in einer
direktwahl will übrigens auch die
meisten leute sollen auch einheitliche
qualität machen
sie sind halt bodo ramelow hat euch mal
eine mehrheit an diesem tag aber ich
habe auch ich habe aber auch an der
stimmen rechnen
abwegigen geschmack aber die sind nicht
so wird die prämie ramelow hatte keine
mehrheit im landtag gegangen sagt das
moralische erpressung er wisse nicht wer
sie müssen ihre wählen weil sonst bricht
nämlich in thüringen alles zusammen und
gegen die fdp muss jetzt auch mal die
cdu-herrschaft mitbringen nicht immer
nur die linken manchmal muss auch die
cdu ein schatten springen sie werden das
sehen sendezeit vorbei die frage ob herr
merz oder herr laschet springen muss und
nicht schatten oder klinge
[Musik]